it is such a pleasure to talk to you
what a season two i mean i blew through
this one but this was really a slow
anticipatory burn of a season wasn't it
what did you want to bring with season
two of bridgerton because there's i
think a little less sex but a little
more build up
i think that's very true that's good i
feel like you know season one and season
two they're very different stories but
they both sort of take us to the same
place and i do think that the
anticipation that bill's in season two
is very hot and steamy and sort of gets
you ready for what comes
this is the season the vi count intends
to find a wife
you honestly just did that i believe i
did
what did you all feel with after the
huge reaction to season one in terms of
doing season two was there pressure what
did you want to deliver for the fans you
know we didn't feel any pressure mainly
because we were already focused on you
know like really just focused on making
season two and making it great so i
wanted us to make you know the best
story we could to take julia quinn's
amazing books and to turn that book to
into something really great and exciting
for the fans that was really our focus
well you did it i mean we did we didn't
miss that reg on page but
we still heard the story of where the
duke is at we got um phoebe to come back
what was it like to bring her back and
could we ever see you work with reggae
again on another one of your many
incredible projects well first of all
the duke is never gone he's always
available on netflix to be binge watched
over and over and over and over as i
like to say and i definitely would work
with reggae again i love him he's a
wonderful man he's a great actor and he
is so so talented so yeah i would be
happy to work with him again we know
that bridgette has been renewed for
seasons three and four already
congratulations amazing will we follow
benedict's story will this stick to the
books what could we expect we're
definitely planning on you know there's
eight eight bridgerton siblings so there
are you know eight books and we're
definitely planning on following each
one of the siblings romantic stories so
we're not necessarily going in order but
we are going to be seeing each one of
the siblings and their stories oh why
aren't we going in order what what's the
decision making well you know we just
got a little bit creative and so we're
already at work hard at work writing
season three so that is already in
progress and you know you'll see it gets
exciting okay you know i gotta ask you
then who's season three
i can't tell you that yet that is the
ultimate spoiler i'd
can you really not see anything engaging
about it yes i suppose i can see how he
might engage
a person
there are so many romantic scenes in
this season i'm thinking of the horse
riding in the rain he scoops her up i'm
shooting to the end now but what is your
favorite scene and what do you love
about the romance of bridgerton you know
especially this season i love the
fireworks i love the the sparks that fly
between the two of them i love how much
they don't you know you they sort of
don't like each other and and how much
that means that they do like each other
i love that sort of feeling between the
two of them the heat that flies so to me
that those are my favorite moments to
watch i also just really enjoy watching
you know the friendship of penelope and
eloise like i i love them as a
friendship pair and i think that i enjoy
that so much it is so incredible the you
know also i mean just as a woman to see
the strong women you've brought to the
screen the diversity of women that
you've brought to the screen in all your
shows but now this season to have the
incredible actresses to have the sharmas
on screen how special did that feel to
bring their stories well you know it was
so wonderful you know they're such great
actresses and bringing them into the
story was so simple to do just because
they fit so perfectly into our world
their wonderful actors and getting that
story told and turning the sheffield
into the sharmas was just a simple
switch that made the story work so
perfectly and we wanted to make sure
that you know people are seeing
themselves represented on screen now
grey's anatomy also renewed for a season
19. you know i got to ask you one grace
question
you could check on this later because
while someone you care about is in
another room getting surgery right now
someone i care about has his brain open
in this room there's always the
discussion of when will it end how will
it end at this point i i've heard you've
rewritten the ending a few times at this
point do you have an idea of how you'd
want the show to end and
is there a world in which it would
continue on even if ellen did finally
say i've got to call it here
well i'm not running grey's anatomy
anymore so creatively i'm not in charge
of how it would end at this point
anymore you know i handed that off and i
went over to netflix so
you know that's a whole other world
last question for you how much do you
enjoy the steeny scenes i have to say
like i'm a little bit blushy i i'm
probably the person who's going like
this a little bit more than most people
i i'm i'm kind of a prude i'm surprised
to say i get a little bit shy i don't
want to sit next to my mom or my sister
or one watch the scenes but i mean
they're pretty see me and good they're
very good i love that um i i interviewed
claudia last week and she told me that
one thing she loves about the show is
doing the table reads with you guys also
betsy beers who i love who's with
shondeland she reads the stage
directions in the read-throughs she
really gets the pace going and so you'll
just hear her being like things are
getting steamy
well you know betsy has done all of the
table reads for like all of our shows
for years and years and years and she is
an expert at them like the betsy beers
table read experience is a
an experience that i wish everybody
could have you know i keep saying we
should film those because just watching
her read the stage directions of any of
our shows has been an experience that
i don't know we could sell tickets and
it would be amazing
[Music]
you